thousands across the midwest are still
struggling to recover after historic
flooding left entire towns and farms
underwater
in a new cbsn originals documentary adam
yamaguchi meets a nebraska farmer
who is reluctant to acknowledge the
realities of climate change
even as extreme weather becomes his new
normal
do you and other farmers here chalk it
up to
it was a freak occurrence the levee
broke or
were you guys talking about larger
climate issues
you know i'm not a climate change guy
as far as you know climate change global
warming whatever any of that stuff
has the climate change yes so those two
words go together
but am i a believer i mean
i haven't seen all the facts i guess
just to make an assumption on my own
but has i has i have i seen the weather
change
in say my 20 year farming career
absolutely do you feel like farmers
around here are talking about climate
more um
i don't think they're talking about
climate change they're talking about
climate the drastic swings in it
i mean it's just like today i mean
you're here it's
it was 50 degrees this morning it's june
in nebraska
it was 90 something last week you know i
mean
that's not normal the sense the sense
that i get is
is that people are noticing changes but
it seems like
the words climate change it's still a a
four-letter word around here
i don't know if it's a i don't know if
climate change is a four-letter word
it's just
you know maybe we're just slow to adapt
i don't know
with us now adam good morning um so he
says he's not a climate change guy the
farmer you interviewed but he
acknowledges that the climate is
changing so as he puts it the words go
together
why his reluctance to not name it as it
is yeah i mean it's a bizarre
conversation
that you can have across the region and
what wasn't just limited to to to brett
this farmer
uh the the widespread sentiment in this
in in these parts is that
the term is so politically charged that
by conceding that climate change is real
and that humans may have a hand in it is
is tantamount to
buying into a certain ideology which
people are just not willing to do
even though he can see his farm is
directly impacted that's what's so
fascinating
right next to uh his farm his farmland
has essentially become a lake he's got 4
000 acres
80 percent of it is still underwater and
yet there's that reluctance to take that
one further step insane
are they linking those floods adam back
in march to climate change so scientists
won't
specifically point to any one storm and
say this is the direct result of climate
change but what they will say is look
climate is in fact changing
and that based on where we are these
like
these events are much more likely to
happen so this is as we would project
and they'll point to the fact that 100
year storms are happening now every five
to seven years
yeah wow the metaphor that always
brought it home for me is is uh the
weather is like a hand of cards
climate change is stacking the deck so
those hands are full of extreme weather
adam thank you very much eye opening
report as always we hope to see you back
soon
you can watch the latest cbsn originals
documentary a climate reckoning in the
heartland
right now it's streaming on cbsnews.com
heartland